un gimnasio que se especializa en la
pérdida de peso ofrece a sus miembros un
programa opcional de dieta por una cuota
adicional para estudiar la eficiencia
del programa de dieta un gerente del
gimnasio toma una muestra aleatoria de
50 miembros que participan en el
programa de dieta y 50 miembros que no
lo hacen
el gerente encuentra que los miembros
que participaron en el programa de dieta
en promedio perdieron considerablemente
más peso que aquellos que no
participaron en el programa en los
últimos tres meses
el gerente concluye que el programa de
dieta provocó el incremento en la
pérdida de peso de los miembros del
gimnasio durante ese lapso de tiempo
entonces pausa el vídeo y reflexiona si
consideras que el gerente llego a una
conclusión válida con base en este
estudio bien primero hay que asegurarnos
que entendemos la conclusión del gerente
el gerente afirma que hay una relación
causal puedes participar en el programa
de dieta genera una mayor pérdida de
peso podría llegar a esta conclusión si
fuera un estudio experimento
bien diseñado y probablemente digas
bueno como es un estudio experimental
bueno en un estudio experimental tienes
un grupo de control que no participa en
el programa de dieta y también tienes un
grupo de tratamiento o grupo
experimental que si participa en el
programa de dieta y entonces podrías ver
si estos individuos efectivamente tienen
una mayor pérdida de peso y si es
estadísticamente significativo
probablemente puedas concluir la
relación causal de que el programa de
dieta provoca la pérdida de peso y esto
parece que es así hasta que piensas en
cómo fueron asignados los individuos en
sus respectivos grupos sería un estudio
experimental bien diseñado
si tomaras una muestra aleatoria de toda
la población tomas una muestra aleatoria
esta es nuestra muestra aleatoria de
toda la población y luego de este grupo
asignas aleatoriamente a los individuos
al grupo de control o al experimental
así que lo distribuyes aleatoriamente y
entonces a las personas asignadas al
grupo
no a las que eligieron estar ahí les
dirías deben hacer esta dieta y te
aseguraría de que en realidad lo
hicieran si después de eso vieras una
mayor pérdida de peso estadísticamente
significativa entonces podrías llegar a
esta conclusión pero eso no es lo que
ocurrió aquí en este caso no
seleccionamos aleatoriamente de toda la
población ni distribuimos aleatoriamente
esa muestra en estos grupos lo que
sucedió es que las personas eligieron
estar o no en el programa de dieta no
escribiré como no están en el programa
de dieta entonces lo que se hizo fue
muestra aleatoriamente de aquellos que
estaban en el programa de dieta para
asignarlos al grupo experimental y
también se muestreo aleatoriamente de
este grupo de control por lo tanto en
esta situación tienes una variable de
confusión significativa las personas
básicamente se postularon al grupo del
programa de dieta y eso lo puedes
considerar como una variable de
confusión y eso no te permite establecer
la relación causal porque las personas
postularon el programa de dieta quizá
estén más motivadas para perder peso tal
vez tienen suficiente dinero y esa
capacidad adquisitiva está relacionada
con una mejor alimentación y por ende
con perder más peso ahora bien una
conclusión a la que el gerente podría
llegar con base en este estudio es que
existe una relación entre participar en
el programa de dieta y perder peso pero
una vez más no puedes establecer una
causalidad hasta el próximo vídeo